hoy en el senado de brasil se vota el
informe final de una comisión
parlamentaria que desde hace seis meses
se investiga la gestión de la pandemia
que en brasil ya ha matado a más de
600.000 personas el presidente y jair
bolsonaro es acusado de 10 crímenes
entre ellos crímenes contra la humanidad
y según aventuran los periódicos locales
podrían caerle hasta 40 años de prisión
la votación va a ser larga durante todo
el día son necesarios 6 votos es decir
una mayoría simple de de los 11
senadores que
integran esta comisión sólo cuatro son a
favor del gobierno también hay que
recordar que los tres hijos de bolsonaro
los políticos de nativos flavio carlos y
eduardo también han sido acusados de
propagar fe news&id y contribuir a la
propagación del virus provocando
manifestaciones y aglomeraciones ahora
bien por ley según la constitución
brasileña el senado sólo puede
investigar
a los testigos quien tiene que proseguir
de forma penal es la fiscalía general
del estado se le pedirá pero el fiscal
general del estado a gusto ahora fue
nombrado a de 2 x bolsonaro y hasta
ahora se ha demostrado muy fiel por eso
que muchos juristas y analistas
políticos creen que toda la comisión se
pueda quedar en la nada como un simple
acto de oposición política también habrá
que ver si los senadores consiguen
presentar este informe al tribunal penal
de la haya para ver si puede ser
condenado por genocidio